hi i am first name and i play character
name in dune and i'm zendaya and i play
chani hi i'm timothy shalom and i play
paula tradies in dune and today we are
with buzzfeed to take the best friend
forever test to see how well we actually
know each other and i'm going to do the
testing
boom
all right doing this their birthday
december 27th september 1st boom their
middle name
hal murray yes i'm sorry i can't get
over the fact that that's your middle
name like whoa
yeah yeah this goes french american
french timothy howe
mommy now you pick me up
chalamet
your favorite snack pasta butter and
cheese that's not really a snack yeah
i'm like trying to think of like what's
your favorite thing would you like fries
i like fries is that like a good snack
we don't eat
the only time
he was two years ago
and when you saw me went
their biggest celebrity crush easy tom
holland
the biggest celebrity crush oh man i
don't actually know maybe that's a
secret on purpose
first time we met for real chemistry
yeah chemistry but at an airport before
but it wasn't me like it wasn't a media
i saw it we saw each other at a distance
yeah i saw her going to first class and
i was like damn
meanwhile he was nominated
um their favorite project viewers i'm
guessing like my favorite project of
yours this is from a previously this
sounds like an awful answer but this is
from previous interview she said the
entire body will work so i'll take that
i'll say and he likes you for it i like
everything too
everything else you did was favorite
memory of you together i can't just say
what my favorite remember i have to
guess what yours is like what you think
my favorite memory of us is oh boy when
you help me get my [ __ ] together
time for yours yeah well i can't say
that but i'd be like my favorite times
the time you helped me clean my
apartment
but it was true we rolled up and i was
like
you need some help
a little tlc it was very much i worked
alive i'm not here often their favorite
swear word um you're always saying
but you know it's interesting i never i
thought that word was so bad and i never
said it until i started hanging around
british people and they say it so often
and then i started saying it and it's in
euphoria a lot and i'm like oh my god
um your favorite cuss word i was gonna
say [ __ ] but then i feel like you say
more than you say like
like you i hear you yeah i'm a pretty
big guy yeah their go-to karaoke song
crazy
you've sang that like four times well it
was like since we've been out here it
was amazing yeah your go-to karaoke i
would probably say anything cuddy no
that's butchering and blasphemy you
don't think i can go anywhere near that
what no you know that although i feel
like though yeah that'd be like a cuddy
song like if you if you it's a point of
karaoke is to like do a song that you
know really well no that's like you
don't want it i can't go near it heart
shaped box i guess that's wrong well i
learned something new today they're
hidden talent in thailand
i guess it's hidden from an amazing
climber because this is some of these
sets on dune they'd be like not a
climber you're like oh can you help me
okay thank you grab my cabins and they
would already be at the top of the cliff
thank you thank you
basically
but graciously this is a graceful
scarier you know i think your hidden
talent which i don't know i don't know
if it's hidden but like your comedic
timing like you're hilarious we were
coming back from from work last night in
a boat and he had the entire boat like
dying yeah like that's like your hidden
talent a little bit okay like that
you're like way funnier than people
actually know well that was fun that was
great that was enlightening we know each
other well enough yeah we have many
years hopefully if we do more of these
movies too really get to know each other
yeah good job what a pleasure please a
pleasure pleasure thank you buzzfeed for
over a decade now helping me to
understand myself through short five
minute quizzes yeah the cornerstones of
my identity
are these quizzes thank you and we hope
you all enjoy doing when it comes out
guys don't make us look dumb
peace
you